this week we've got yanil coffee shits
and senior prank what do you guys are
you here I heard yaaaa first yeah all I
hear is Laurel same but I like found up
now I can only hear both of the same
time because the higher frequency says
yeah me a little lower one says Laurel I
hear yerry do you get I hear morale it's
weird because I hear I don't give a [ __ ]
that's so crazy you're not funny you're
a loser you're going to floors not
though if you listen to it close I'm
like this but it sounds different oh
really
yeah I really learned a job you can hear
the Laurel more but if you listen to a
far away it sounds different yeah
because you can't hear the undertone
yeah when I had it close I heard Laurel
yeah well if someone else is playing it
I heard Yan literally when I saw that
they're like you hear Laurel at whatever
I heard I can't remember what it was I
like Cole please move on and that was it
not for me when I first pressed played I
heard yeah Laurel if you don't know what
we're talking about you missing out on
life
cuz this is all the right David you're
not above it okay oh you so y'all heard
two words that's crazy
I like his heater Gary I don't know what
the [ __ ] what did you hear Morrill I
heard em in there yeah so all this
started with his youtuber named Chloe
Feldman she tweeted out this which says
what do you hear yeah near Laurel and it
was this video I can't believe there's
only two choices you two ready yeah yeah
me yeah me
I hear Laurel I hear Lee hear Laurel
that I heard it from a different thing
me too I heard it had a beat oh really
yeah I gave you a different one
oh the one you gave me has a video had
like a beat and minister no it played
that I heard Laurel after Jess said do
you hear Laurel oh she asked she played
it she know she played at issues like
what you hear and I go I hear Gary oh
and she goes you you don't hear Laurel
and I go
I hear Laurel yeah cuz you know when you
hear the word and then you you yeah you
think that and you go oh it does sound
like that yeah that's like perception
like if no one told you what does power
of suggestion this thing this effect
it's called something Oh like the same
thing with the blue dress Oh like the
Eisenhower effect no but it's it's fun
Kennedy effect I don't know but it's a
it's like a scientific thing that it
happens all the Lincoln moves yeah well
yeah tea and Laurel would so they say it
at the same time yeah then it's probably
like a frequency thing there is the
yanny and the lower frequency is the
lord but it's fine funny ruiner maybe
it's because like they've already done
this a few times so I remember when they
did the dress thing yourself a dress
blue dress yeah right and I got an audio
but this yeah this happens and it also
I've already went through it so the
video so there's another video
explaining like this whole effect and
then they show you of this guy saying um
[ __ ] what is he saying like bad harder I
think he's saying like you things like
bad or something and he's keep saying
bad bad bad right
and then it's the exact same then he
says fad if they're at the beach or
something right you know it's in a room
okay but if he's saying the same word
over and over and over
yeah but then you you look at his lips
and then you start hearing yeah I'm
saying something else exactly thank you
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
like in high school they had this they
would do these like they'll do the same
[ __ ] so you'll say stop stop stop stop
stop and you'll switch the word to shop
and you'll tell the person to say it
again and they'll say stop instead it's
like that I learned all of this in the
psychology I'm giving you that's it
that's kind of cool because perception
it's like it's it depends on what the
individual perceives that's the reality
yeah so there's no real right or wrong
here it's just your perception as you're
hearing starts going and like as you
older and your hearing starts going you
stop being able to hear higher
frequencies so if you don't hear Janna
you're wrong well I would be so funny
somebody starts playing it and they just
don't hear anything at all I was first
listening to this like super late last
night so I was just like trying to focus
I'm like I want to hear Yanni I want to
hear and then why do you want to hear it
because that way
flip like flip but if you some people
were doing the thing where they sped up
and slowed down the thing and the more
got sped up you could hear the other one
there was like a tool that I think the
New York Times said it or someone made a
tool where you could like speed it up or
slow it down and it would go to Laurel
or une depending on what he did know but
then I started hearing like like Laurel
was the main thing I heard but then
under I could hear like oh it was like
so for someone like me what is that what
is the like why is it so fascinating
because it's what's people into I think
because the mind is so like [ __ ]
mysterious it's really interesting to
see things like this where both parties
are like this is a hundred percent what
I hear yeah and it kind of bleeds into
other aspects of life where people are
100 percent on their side and they can't
see from another person's perspective at
all and then the other person is like
how can you not see this perspective I
can't see yours at all and it's like
kind of an analogy no you don't you like
[Laughter]
it just cut it crazy cuz yeah like I
just fun and games okay cool it's nice
to label people and call them wrong okay
yeah it's just it's just fun that's what
it is yeah it's like no-one's like
losing our I'm pretty sure a lot of
people might be losing but we're in this
room no one's losing sleep over it it's
just fun tonight because I saw people
just go I was like oh and it's fun to
alienate people like if you're like I
hear Laurel but everyone else hears
Hannity we're like you're wrong just
stop being a downer bro I don't hear the
area anymore - but I saw that [ __ ] I
started cracking oh [ __ ] this Melissa I
hear yeah okay you know this tweet is
not a joke he legit heard Gary yeah so
it's all started when a Georgia High
School student was trying to study the
word Laurel she was trying to find the
definition of what Laurel is Laurel
Canyon and so she went to vocabulary
calm and she hit the pronunciation
recording and that's when she heard an e
she was like what the hell so she shared
it on Instagram and that's when it is
where I like fire because then on
Twitter that's when this youtuber Chloe
filming
tweeted it out and then that's when it's
great even more robots never pronounce
[ __ ] right anyway my GPS always [ __ ]
up Spanish yeah I know that's why I try
to learn Spanish from Spanish for an
audition because it gave me the line in
English but it said say it in Spanish my
manager was like I don't know Spanish
what'd I do he's like just learn it in
Spanish so I learned it from the google
translator she forgot she had met javi
and I did I forgot to about Mexican
friends that know Spanish
that's so funny though I learned Spanish
what did you say I own a bike remember
now it's like la posada simon egg
vamos milk cuatro scientist and that as
they do see it sounds like to me the
computer would like la CIMA not be in be
ammos you said the heavy you said the
last the heavy last week yeah I like it
when the GPS is trying to pronounce
Hawaiian words like streets and stuff
when you're in Hawaii oh yeah la Avenue
for a next story this woman in Canada
was trying to use a Tim Hortons bathroom
when apparently one of the employees
recognized her from a previous time that
she used the restroom and so they denied
her the restroom and she was so mad all
the way Tim Hortons is like their Dunkin
donut shop got you I loved him morons
she was so upset that she did she took
it what does she do it's pretty gross
right so they wouldn't let her use the
restroom because they saw her but no no
they just watch this [ __ ] watching
you'll be fine me Kendu yeah so they
because she had use the restroom in the
past I don't know what exactly was
graphic warning guys [ __ ] graphic
crap now I want to see it more ready
it's pretty bad
she's gonna [ __ ] him up watch he's crazy
I can't do this oh oh you don't want me
to use the bathroom [ __ ] I gotta
go oh yeah it's all sped up - it's like
Three Stooges and [ __ ]
Oh taking off her sweater [ __ ] you up
just watch
Oh watch [ __ ] oh no wait for it
dude - you [ __ ] game paint on them
she did a drive-by [ __ ] good and no
getting robbed
I wouldn't interview dude he throw be
throwing around I'm running away I'm
telling you this right now like that to
me if somebody shat on the floor and try
to chuck it at me that's ten times worse
than you throwing a fist dip yeah I
would literally go over I was snap her
[ __ ] arms off like I don't give a
[ __ ] if you're if you don't [ __ ] at me I
would freak the [ __ ] out with that
person I rather get shot cuz if I
already have [ __ ] on it doesn't matter
we're Dukey anyways now that is a
[ __ ] snap your [ __ ] arm up they
should so grow if someone did that to me
I think I would start a slow clap is
some [ __ ] new [ __ ] respect I would
run away [ __ ] I start screaming it's
primal yeah you've got an article to
connect us to [ __ ] primates do
because she legit they are connected no
I'm saying like you know some people
deny it
yeah that's gonna be one of our black
dude monkeys are literally the worst
versions of humans like they have all of
our negative traits they rape they
murder
Vicky they really yeah they kill their
own babies they eat they eat babies from
other tribes they rip apart their limbs
that you don't even though they're
vegetarians Ackerman was it I think was
a Sacramento Zoo it was a Sacramento Zoo
or they saw a [ __ ] chimpanzee just
call it - there's other [ __ ] chimp
and he kept on tugging at his dick and
clearly the chip didn't like thing
stopped right and it was chilling like
this again he just comes up you didn't
like seven times and the fool is getting
sick of it like you could tell if you
could speak English you [ __ ] bro you
know and he just chilled went back to it
went to another part of the tree full
fathom again God is big [ __ ] [ __ ] he
kicked his ass or nah they just started
chasing each other but every time he
calmed down buddy yanking on his dick
the worst part human
they see like oh this annoys you I'm
gonna keep up ow I felt so bad for that
piece
I saw this little baby monkey go trying
to eat some food and this big adult
monkey was like whoa you don't think he
took holy [ __ ] it's crazy because they
have a sense of humor yeah I saw this
one monkey pick up a big ass dirt pile
dump it on another monkey's head and he
[ __ ] laugh so hard so we're in Bali
and in the monkey jungle and you're not
supposed to take anything in there cuz
the monkey will steal you think you had
they'll steal it so I saw his dude with
a bottle of water and I we had bottles
of water and the monkeys kept trying to
steal it but this one [ __ ] fool
they're [ __ ] it's one dude in front
of us this little monkeys there's
different types of monkeys the little
monkey comes up steals his water bottle
and the dudes like oh like give me my
water bottle and he's like yeah and then
he goes to open it and this bigger
monkey comes up behind them whack them
in the head takes the water bottle opens
it and pours it in front of the little
monkeys face and you just wait till it's
all emptied and it goes if you don't let
them never been to a zoo [ __ ] every
other animal dude just go to like the
monkey and hate exhibit dude there was
this one time so you're the best when
the San Diego Zoo [ __ ] huge ass
gorilla this was the saddest thing
though so he was so this other gorilla
want it I'm not talk or whatever hang
out with this other girl and the other
girl literally just pushed him aside and
this fool will got so sad I'm not even
[ __ ] [ __ ] you he walks up to a
tree and there's just one little leaf he
just goes yeah do my brother and I were
laughing our asses off dude Oh wild dude
you know how they're feeling
yeah going back to the [ __ ] throwing
though I want to know David is it worse
if someone throws [ __ ] or a period pad
the third I'll take a period pad me
your faith in eighth period before she
validate for that yeah it happened
expects to hear that there is blood is
better than Dookie yeah I feel like it's
more sanitary is it yeah it doesn't
smell no waste product yeah I mean like
if you get a cut
you suck the you know blood out it's
tough it's fine but I won't suck the
Dookie out of my own butt yeah this will
always try to say [ __ ] to be inclusive
in a conversation but he just checks
himself like yeah this way was your ID
in the period before violence hey we are
eat eggs
that's all period you eat blood and save
what eggs our periods did that's true
honey part is just the egg part yeah but
I mean it's like a bloody you you can't
come back in this conversation he's like
I ate your period that's a period
chicken periods no no oh my god except I
remember that girl from long time ago
she took her tampon out and oh she
sucked on it
that's nasty well I can't I can't deal
with [ __ ] like that like bodily fluids
it tastes just like burgers like um like
the heat value of iron from it a lot of
it though I wouldn't do it I'm not
condoning that [ __ ] cold place could be
you keep all your iron that's why it's
like I lit if I had a shot my light
everybody just use the [ __ ] bathroom
cuz I don't want them to take a [ __ ] on
themselves I know what if but they might
have been like a crackhead that just
uses it for hours she's like maybe she's
shat all over the bathroom because they
said they've seen her before
they're like I remember I had a clean up
[ __ ] Dookie from the roof cuz of your
ass she's also lucky she didn't meet
anybody crazy though cuz as soon as she
started [ __ ] if the cashier was
crazy and grabbed her hair and just
started pounding her face washes oh no
and then crazy mad crazy she might think
Oh ash of her face in her own [ __ ] yeah
so she didn't meet crazy it was just she
was the only person that was great she
was in the perfect position where if he
just kicked her leg she would have fell
and sat on her own Duke
oh yeah she was fast yeah she was quick
she went crash grabbed it in hospital
but they split up fiber though like that
was some drippy [ __ ] yeah she was ready
to go eat some broccoli or some bread
that was a lot of [ __ ] it was so much
she was about to explode I mean you
can't mess with people when they need a
[ __ ] though that like that's me I know
I've actually seen someone [ __ ] on the
side of the road when there was like
bumper-to-bumper traffic on the road oh
I've seen somebody [ __ ] on the road
multiple times in Sacramento yes you
just happened to see it when I went
there you're looking for it that's what
I don't know if the middle of the
freeway is looking for it but all right
when I went back to Sacramento a couple
of times but not the last time but the
time before that my best Knar picked me
up and we were on this overpass that's
next to my house
this lady literally got out of her car
and we thought that her car broke down
she came out well she did take a [ __ ]
but she came out pulled her pet and she
started pissing in the middle of the
[ __ ] like overpass it was [ __ ]
insane dude this guy I've almost done
that I pissed in my car once like annek
coffee mug I used to have to commute
from Santa Barbara to LA for auditions
and you know LA traffic is insane and
we're not living in it every day you
don't really plan for that and I was in
bumper-to-bumper traffic and it got so
bad like where your seat belt is like
cutting into your bladder and like it
hurts to move and I'm like holy [ __ ] I
need to get out so then I pulled off the
the nearest exit but but it took forever
to get to that exit and then there was
no bathrooms anywhere and nothing was
open it was like 8:00 in the morning so
there was nothing there so I went to a
neighborhood and I took the like coffee
cup that I had in my car because it was
like one of those gas station coffees
and I just like I just had to pee in my
car and it got everywhere I got because
I filled up the coffee like I stopped it
but only a little bit cause it was like
going full force it was like a fire hose
all those things the [ __ ] I don't
know what it's the girl ones right the
snappa dick would you put the funnel
funnel tamping funnels down but I was
pretty good at aiming it just filled the
entire 40 ounce of cuppa
the best emergency Pete in the match
yeah it was nuts
Oh dad did you keep the couple you throw
it away oh I kept it as a souvenir let's
discuss it you drank out of it when you
went over to our house that makes it
alright for our last story police
praised these high school students for
the best prank they've ever seen okay so
this is the police department in
Wisconsin it says hats off to the
Cumberland high school class of 2018 on
your senior prank congratulations class
of 2018 and one of the best senior
pranks a oh that looks really good yeah
what's the prank so they got a car from
a junkyard like half of a car oh they
painted it and then this is near the
principal's office too and so they got
em they got like a whole bunch of paper
bags and like a whole bunch of black
things
oh it's crazy like a whole into it
that's clever
how do they get that half a car there
that's it take a [ __ ] tow truck or
something yeah how BIG's your pranks go
pretty far yeah they've been they've
done senior pranks when they put a car
on top of a flagpole before oh [ __ ] they
did the goat thing on the roof and all
this other stuff we did that on Jay King
he was a long time ago did you guys ever
do a senior prank we didn't do ended up
being vandalism I got like neon orange
paint and I just painted dicks all over
that at school
yeah that's just bad the loser that's
not a prank bro what's that mean no I
didn't get to be a senior no I signed
myself out of school when I was like 16
or 17 whatever the legal age was and
then I went to adult schoo nice they did
the thing where they chained all the
lockers together no I did I did the
thing where I just didn't show up
anymore
yeah yeah the senior praise our people
for the kids who actually liked school
really like most of us want to remember
school forever we didn't go to like what
do you call those things those those
where they try to cheer the whole school
pep rallies yeah pep rallies yeah I mean
either we didn't do that there was a
spot by the pep rally if you snuck
around
there was like back bushes you could go
all the way behind the baseball field
and I mean smoke weed yeah that make
sense damn so the secret to success in
life is to not have that spirit yeah
don't be that doubt about school people
that were that way they like look back
on those days I was like they're like
they're like all remember in high school
was so cool this I'm like I don't want
to remember any part of high school when
I go back to Sacramento there's like a
couple of homies you know I mean so like
their their their peaks of their lives
as high school so even till this day
right after 4000 years after high school
you'll remember high school I don't
loser what the [ __ ] are you talking
about dude design those were the good
doesn't know what good these are now
yeah you know I mean no man high school
was traumatic for me seriously I'm still
[ __ ] suffering PTSD from that [ __ ]
era it's crazy that the peak of their
life was the age of 14 and it never got
better it's like dude your life sucks
bro I know that's like saying remember
when we were six yeah that's actually a
good times though that is the good times
[Music]
[Music]